foreign
[Music]
good afternoon welcome to sogcast number
17. my name is John Striker Meyer I'll
be your host today for the podcast uh we
also start out by thanking our sponsor
Jocko willing Productions and Corsa
Chronicles with a little support element
here
we thank him for this show and with this
we move forward with our next interview
and we have no set format here so today
we have a unique opportunity for me my
time in SOG was spent entirely on recon
team Idaho
and today I'm joined by another member
of the team because during the secret
Warrior ran for eight years and Idaho
was one of the first five or six teams
that was set up during that eight-year
secret war and throughout that time the
team had been wiped out twice
once in 66 or 67 and then in May of 68
that's how I got my job I ran Recon
there and then years later was followed
up by other men who served time and
today we're joined by Frank pulley who
was on Idaho in 1971 and every one of
our assault members that we've
interviewed has a unique story and Frank
welcome and thank you for coming in
today taking time to visit us and uh I
wish we could start off right from the
top you were strap hanging with rt
Louisiana and uh before you landed on
Idaho and talk a little bit about your
time there sure thank you John yes first
of all for having me
um
a number of uh good friends of mine we
all went through training group phase
one went through we all decided we
wanted to be weapons
oh yes so we all went through weapons
together and what's the time frame on
that Frank that was uh in uh 70 uh the
um in part we got our flashes we had
already been through training group and
that kind of stuff around Thanksgiving
of 70. okay we were all Green Berets at
that point Green Berets that's right
real estate and we had finished all our
training and we were being assigned as
you can recall the initial days of being
in Special Forces you never knew what
group you were going to be with and that
kind of stuff
um that at that particular time sixth
group was still active it had not at
Fort Brag correct yeah and uh
I was assigned there and a lot of the
other guys we had several that went to
Okinawa and most everybody wound up in
fifth quite honestly but when the sixth
closed out and they were folded into
other things I finally wound up in the
fifth also
we all went down they were eight of us I
think it was and we all went down to
headquarters and we all signed up for
Vietnam at the same time you know first
sergeant he was thrilled to death
because he was trying to get people to
you know look at southeast Asia well we
all decided we were going to be career
soldiers all of us sure at that
particular point in time so we knew that
the only way that we were going to be
looked at anything down the road
was if we had a little time you know in
the bush sure and also just for a
reference for our listeners uh by 1970
at the end of 1970 the secret War had
been going on for six years
and the Vietnam War at that point
Vietnamization was in in place that's
correct under President Nixon they're
scaling back the American presence in
Vietnam particularly with combat troops
but the missions for SOG became more
critical it also became more dangerous
and a lot of that support was going away
and the support was always a faction but
even 1970 and early part 1971
um that was still a one more challenge
that added to the game and challenge of
being on the ground and surviving your
time on the ground so with that
historical background you gentlemen
volunteered for Vietnam right at the end
of 1970 and they'll take it for near
Frank
um we
uh were back on the assigned a teams
that we had for a while
and then once our orders came down uh SF
had started its uh 1-0 school here at
Bragg oh that's right long time had one
in country but they had they recognized
reconnaissance school at McCall
yeah and uh so all of us wound up going
through the one zero school here at BRAC
and they said okay when you hit the
ground in Vietnam there's not going to
be a delay in long time or anything you
will be able to go straight to a Recon
team wow and we said okay well then we
were like kids
you know young adult and young and dumb
and and full of you know peanut butter
and uh nothing much in Pennsylvania that
too and uh
I think there's another one in there
somewhere but I forgot it but yeah yeah
easy now but anyway uh we all went
through that and then we were given our
leave before going overseas
we wound up at Fort Lewis and then how
long was that Recon school at Bragg it
was on just over six weeks six yes okay
so that way you've like when I went we
had in country training at the end of
the in country training the sergeant
comes up we're looking for volunteers
for what can't say either you're in or
out but in your case you guys knew ahead
of time we knew that we were going to
the projects it was like
projects you know okay you're being
groomed you're being trained you
uh I mean where else would we have
gotten any wiretap training sure we got
that at the 1-0 school Hill here at
Bragg and that includes the
helicopter repelling oh Wayward Etc
patrolling yeah the first time uh I was
ever in a chopper that auto rotated no
my grip is still in the door of the
helicopter if it and this has been
scrapped I didn't know what auto
rotation was until they introduced us to
it right and um
it was an experience but nevertheless
when you survived that's right that's
right so we went to uh
I used to bring a lot of these guys home
with me
on the weekends and so we decided that
what we would do is on a particular day
I left home because I was the
easternmost one and the one that lived
the furthest west was in Seattle and
what we would do is I would start out
early go to the next ones
home right spend a day or so meet their
parents
then he and I would leave and go to the
next one we wound up
my home Tennessee South Dakota wow Texas
and
um up to Seattle
and we all got on the same plane once we
did our little thing and so who are some
of the US if you don't mind oh no not at
all we had um very good friend he was
our Mexican Buddy Joe Harrow
um and we had
Steve Dawkin
uh he on I think it was his second
mission actually he um
was closed Steve's just in front of the
tail Gunner
and they took a b40 rocket the tail
Gunner did yeah on the uh anyway it hit
him they ascertained that the tail
Gunner got hit right in square of the
back with a b40 rocket and it blew him
in two but
sadly what happened was the doctor said
that one of the vertebrae
of the tail Gunner
came forward and it took Doc's hand off
I mean it was a clean
took it off and and he was right-handed
of all things so but South Dakota and
we wound up right outside the gates of
uh Fort Lewis and Mike Lawson a very
dear friend of mine he uh he and I uh
actually he ran on one team I ran on
another he ran on Rhode Island
and he was very good Recon guy yeah
Rhode Island was one of the best Recon
teams up there they were just sharp yeah
and they're in digits were just
amazingly strong with the program that's
exactly right indeed so anyway uh so we
go to uh fly in and
um we had one guy with us that uh he had
already been this was his second tour
and uh the receiving company there I
mean it was a
typical Army well organized and oiled
machine getting people into where they
needed to go and we knew that we were
going to wind up uh in the train right
so we had to go there before we could uh
wind up in our final destination where
we got to the triangle in about two days
and we were interviewed
by several sergeant majors
they're in the train I don't know if
that happened to you or not or maybe
they just gave you an assignment but all
three projects were beginning to cut
back a little bit right and uh
I think it was Sergeant Major Darcy
was the sergeant major that interviewed
each of us and the others they were just
there kind of for support more than
anything else and some of the guys that
did not go over with us but were there
for the interview before they had gotten
their assignments
um everybody was like whatever you do
don't don't go north don't go north yeah
you know and you know we were like well
we don't see the big deal you know but
yeah well we were going to find out
pretty quickly you know but anyway uh
rather than it being a formal interview
sergeant major it was kind of like your
dad talking to you yeah sure and that's
the way he wanted to the Persona to uh
come across
and um
he asked me he said Sergeant pulley he
says where do you think you might want
to go and I said well I'm here because
you know the ins and outs of what
special forces is doing in in Vietnam he
says well what do you think I said
if I'm going to get
a career
I said I'm going to have to get in this
war
and he says I think I can help you with
that
and I said oh wow okay whatever and then
say several of us wound up uh going up
and we left the train in two more days
we were signing in there at CCN
and uh
so I got my wish you know I tell you
they had a uh you remember the repellent
Tower oh sure
and uh
they um
all of us together what they did they
had uh not the wooden Tower but the
ladders remember the ladders that came
off the side right those were their
leader and uh yeah they wouldn't well it
was
laid out for us like uh you really want
to go to Recon company you know because
you're going to have opportunities to do
things oh yeah well this has got to be
us you know and so right now it's
January of 71. it's uh no it's around
April or so oh April okay because we
went
but anyway so we uh
they said in order to go to Recon
company
you've got to climb that with the 30
pound sandbag in your rucksack oh yeah
and it was no
uh this is what you need to do now as
you know your experience on ladders if
you don't climb it from the side
your legs kick out
and you're trying you're pulling
everything out with your arms and you
get no leverage from your legs it's all
well upper body
total plus 30 pounds yeah plus plus
you're saying so anyway
um we had one guy I won't call his name
but he did not make it up and we after
about five rungs up the ladder unless
you dumb is dirt you realize I got to
get around on the side of this thing I'm
looking like I'm screwing a bulldog here
yeah you know so you get around and at
least it'll help you look yeah so
me and several other guys we were lucky
and we got to the tower got to the top
and then they said well come on down
we'll assign you some stuff well
they knew which teams
needed people on them at that particular
time RT Louisiana was in the field
when uh
uh James bath he was helping assign
people
was that right yes they're famous JD
Beth who was there in the very beginning
is that wrong he was he Jim Jim hetrick
they were there and um wasn't he on uh
um
relay radio relay Hickory or something I
think that he was there so many
different times he he covered it all
yeah and there's that there was a
History Channel production called the
suicide missions that they changed it to
dangerous missions and now they've
changed it again but JD bath is
interviewed there talking about the
early days going out and recruiting
people for the teams with the tobacca
and the pipes and things and so this is
so JD was here in the beginning this is
71 the seventh year of District Awards
he's back uh where they made amazing
absolutely one of our studs yeah yeah
that's right and uh
anyway uh he said your team the one I'm
going to assign you to
they are on a mission right now
and uh you'll have to wait for them to
come back
uh when so y'all can iron things out
find out kind of where you are what
you're going to be doing and that kind
of stuff I said that's fine
and um
well all my other buds now they got
picked up
and uh one wound up on uh on the hatchet
force that at you know where they could
raid and that kind of stuff sure he
didn't make it to Recon but you know it
was like Camp Security Plus we'll go out
on rage kind of local you know things
sometimes they had to go into support
teams that are like in 69 we had a
reconting with Elton barswell's team hit
a base camp that was relatively stayed
behind the next day Hatchet force would
Mad Dog Survivor went in and they loaded
15 helicopters with documents and Intel
stuff
so Hatchet force would do that too and
of course security because they had to
have you know base security was still a
question and a challenge that she's
saying always a challenge
but um
so I I was homeless if you will and it
was really really fortuitous in the fact
that uh he said dump your gear here and
when you win zero gets back then y'all
can iron stuff out and then figure out
what you're going to do I said great
well uh there was a spare bunk that was
unmade so I said well obviously this is
going to be mine right here and when I
set my gear down
I could not believe what I saw in the
fact that the one zero was his name was
John levister
his one one was Ray frovarp oh my God
now I didn't know when either one of
them but I looked there was a small desk
set up which obviously was what we three
were going to share to write a letter
home or whatever well there were a
couple of letters lying on the desk I
was not prime but I was being observant
and his wife had written him a letter
in her return address said she was
Oriental
I think it was Lynn frovar or whatever
it was and she had written him a letter
from Zebulon North Carolina
my
Hometown no
yes talk about small world and I'm
talking I said now what is this all I
cannot believe I mean where I'm from
they don't even put it on the map some
of the times you know what I'm saying
and there's a letter from his wife from
my hometown and I'm going
this is weird so anyway uh
he's passed on now sadly but uh
not very frovar Ray's still alive Ray is
that's right yes but John passed away I
guess it's been over 20 years ago
perhaps I don't know sure but anyway
um
we
I didn't have anything to do I was kind
of you know all I could do was PT and I
didn't even have a a decent weapon that
I had had issued to me I had an old wore
out
[Music]
oh yeah you know this kind of stuff they
didn't want me to walk around naked but
it was the next best thing you know and
weapon wise and
um so uh
um Noel gas he was the uh 1-0 of Idaho
and Bob Castillo he uh he was the one at
that time that's right yes and um
we had the Recon club that most people
would congregate uh at and either play
cards or you know drink beer or
something drink a little drink a little
yeah talk a little something to grease
you up you know get you where you could
move good you know and before and after
you go to the mess hall right around the
corner that's right and uh so uh uh I
met both of them uh in the club and and
they said well who are you and I said
well I'm Frank pulley I just got it you
know down here with some other guys
and uh said but it's going to be a while
it looks like before I'm gonna get a
chance to do anything and uh Bob uh
Castillo he said um
well we got a mission that we're going
to get prepped for tomorrow so do you
want to go with us and I said yeah
yeah I'm beat yeah let's do it you know
yeah and um
so I went and talked with James and he
said well you your team's in the field
and they're not getting out of the field
until the weather breaks the helicopters
are not going to fly into that mountain
trying to find them and I said well
that's probably a wise thing to do so we
go up to fubai I get my little stabo and
this is after you guys went to S4 got
all your equipment got your car 15. no I
still had my M16 no oh yeah because it
was you know a couple it wasn't long
anyway yeah indeed
and um
so you go up to the food by launch site
we do and uh so they're explaining the
mission to me and then all of a sudden
there were several teams up there uh for
different uh missions and one was RT
Kansas
uh yeah they were there and this is
still April though
well now this particular thing I just
told you I misspoke I'm sorry uh uh this
was uh
um you might want to back some of that
out or something so I always made a
mistake okay anyway
of August oh okay now that's a very
significant period of time yes with the
historic now historic art team Kansas
mission in the Oscar 8. that's right
indeed
uh they according to what uh Bingham was
lost right on that
um
he was lost as a matter of fact uh me
and one of my buds picked him up on a
bright light yes this was all a bright
light wow is that with Idaho yes no
kidding yeah
and um
so just for a little background Franklin
that was a heavy Mission they went into
Oscar 8 they went in with five Americans
and five in ditch and got hammered yes
and within the and the lieutenant Hagen
was the 1-0 he was killed early but
earned the Medal of Honor he did and
he's buried in Arlington today and then
uh Bingham was Kia and then uh every
American was wounded to understand
another and Anderson Tony Anderson right
was in uh Berg
he was never found I don't know if
they've had any luck finding him
no he's still my is he still am I yes
sir and then um we had uh Bill Queen yes
who earned the DSC he did and uh on that
mission multiple wounds and we lost Bill
several years ago also but on that
mission he was he survived it somehow
with all his wounds he was never the
same when somebody told me it had
difficulty absolutely and so you so at
some point Idaho goes in on a bright
light yes
and we were prepped for our insertion
the next day but they extracted the
following morning at first light Tony
Queen
um
the little people and that kind of stuff
and then we went in afterwards to
retrieve the bodies that's the primary
reason for us going in the next day and
you went in under heavy gunfire did they
no really no we did not we got fire once
we got on the ground it was like one of
the tactics they would use quite often
it was you know you might not get
anything unless you were going in on
something you know this as good as I
that they really didn't want you knowing
about right
they would let you come in
let your putts around sometimes
sometimes
and then when you were extracted that's
when all hell broke loose indeed that's
when they wanted to get Crews on the
ground
as many casualties as they can that's
right and the birds were used for you
know
or anything that they could do to create
more
um responsibility getting Crews off the
ground and all this other kind of stuff
um but we did need to call in a1as as a
matter of fact uh Bob Castillo was
working a1e that day and uh
several of the helicopters that was
enough
uh
um I guess
remnants of what was left around the
base of the hill is actually a saddle
if you will and they were in the saddle
we no they were on the highest point
okay sounds like it was and that's where
we were picking up most of the stuff
they thought they had enough people I
guess to where they could you know uh
thwart any kind of threat they would
have from the lower elevations on that
Hill
but anyway that's where we got everybody
off was the next so your first mission
is a bright light we retrieved two or
three American bodies yeah
and Berg it was um
Noel
told me he said I want you down here
he says I want you to go off the hill
and go down to Berg's Foxhole and see if
he if he slumped down in Foxhole
I said okay so anyway
it was about 35 meters off the crest of
the Hill
and it could be a long 35 meters
yeah it can and because it was a bare
red heel I mean there was no cover on
there like that that same kind of clay
from case on there red clay yep exactly
but
um
we picked up Hanson he he was shot up
pretty bad I really was and Berg's uh
M60
uh was rendered
inoperable it had taken around I'm
assuming an AK round through the top
feed cover right and so it was locked up
he he was couldn't do anything
and uh two as little people were killed
then Foxhole you know so they stayed
with him until you know that kind of
stuff so
anyway that was my first real mission of
stuff was just walking to the secret War
that's right that's right so from when I
first got there to other stuff it was
local
uh uh patrols sure
and the mess that kind of goes with it
monkey mountain training and all this uh
you know which was like a cakewalk I
thought you know but after your first
mission
so so you come back and where first of
all you took the three-point M16 on that
mission that's right you know thank God
but anyway it would shoot that was the
main thing oh yeah if you cook good care
of them those work we had the better
ammo they wouldn't jam up on you that's
right anyway so you come back to base
then you go back to Louisiana
I like this guy at that point well
that's what Bob did he talked to uh JD
and uh he says I think we're going to
keep him
and I said you know I said well that's
good I enjoy working with these guys
sure and I tell you uh I told Bob today
I said you don't remember this I said
but some things
that are done for people you never
forget and I said you know you saved my
life probably and you really didn't even
remember it
and he said I don't know what are you
talking about I said you remember when
uh before the bright light uh on Kansas
and he said yeah I said they called and
requested several
extra cases of grenades both he and
Willy Pete and he said and I said you
and I flew to helicopter out to resupply
them that night and he said it seems
like I remembered that I said well we
got to the top of the hill
and sat down
just about Twilight
and uh I said nothing's going to happen
out here tonight I said look at all the
guys we got out here I said why don't
you just I mean our mission's canceled
because all the assets are
yeah
I said um why don't you just let me
spend the night that's what their whole
mission is about is they were going to
do uh a leave behind yeah you know
and I said I'll just stay one night
I said it won't be a big deal and I'll
come out with them in the morning
and he sat there and he said
he said no I'm not going to let you get
off he said stay on the helicopter give
them their hand grenades yeah give them
the hand grenades and he says you're
going to go back with me I can't give
you I said all right whatever
oh I told him I said I could kiss you
right on the mouth no delay later down
the road we talked about a mission
that's good to miss or that one when
they get overrun in the morning that one
lost they hit him at first light and uh
they come to find out there was a um it
was a pipeline fuel a fuel line that was
running along the bottom of that Hill
that they were trying to keep any of the
Recon dreams from finding they didn't
want
Intel to get back oh yeah they've got we
were looking for that damn thing as far
back as 68. well they put them right
down on top of it just about and that is
the reason for the assault on the hill
is what we were told later okay that
makes it I never knew that okay they
said they could hear the tailgates of
the Russian trucks dropping oh yeah
we've heard that before to allow the
troops to get off the NVA sure
mess anyway so so you come back you're
permanently assigned to Idaho correct
and then we run a couple missions Bob
and I had Noel Gast went on a
you know how these missions just pop up
and they want somebody to go look at
something you know you're going to go
out and you can come back and oh well
no oil
and uh Quang Doty Quang
yes and JT bath
went out along with
um I almost believe Colonel belfi went
with them now that's unusual to have a
high-ranking office here at the gate he
went on the hill with us on the bright
light really yes
because he
gassed
they were online with me going down the
hill from me to get to Bergs all right
so yeah yeah
Donnie D belfi he was there no kidding
everybody was amazed that there was a
man
officer on the rim wow and I said well
you know anyway this was good you know
but um
they went on a quick Recon of something
and they got engaged by Friendly Fire a
pink team
uh opened upon them they thought they
were bad dudes
and uh bath got hit
gassed got hit he actually
um left and that was the end of his
career running right Recon with that and
Quang got a bad
upper leg wound he was in the hospital
before probably about two months three
no kidding yeah their Hospital in the
compound yes and uh
so artiano who was
at about half
power for a while and then so Bobby
becomes a 1-0 bob is the one zero you
good instant promotion oh you know I do
and a pay raise yeah I forgot that part
yeah but
um and then uh we ran a couple of uh
missions that um we luckily didn't lose
anybody that kind of stuff and probably
I guess uh the mission that we did very
well and were probably fairly proud of
one that we were able to prep for and
actually
uh run it and then get in and get out
and that kind of stuff and that was we
blew a bridge which
um the um seventh Air Force what we were
told uh they had been trying to get rid
of for a while
and uh they just couldn't get proper
angle uh you know you would think a art
light would be part of it but it was it
was basically
um a dirt and uh large teak wood tree
Springers that kind of stuff I mean it
would support track vehicles
and uh so we paired up with another team
uh our team Michigan I think it was now
our team was Vietnamese and the middle
yard team they were yards and so by that
time Eldon Boswell had left right he was
no longer on a team
um because he earned his DSC with
Michigan but I think that was early 71.
I'm not sure that's okay well he wasn't
there the question was is he there when
you were there Bob Bolton was running
that team okay very good sure and uh so
anyway we paired up and um we how'd that
go
right the yards on one team they were
able to oh they went went fine it was uh
we uh actually took that bridge out with
um
40 pound cratering charges I won't stand
off I think it was six of them six yes
that we uh rigged we uh how big was the
bridge
oh it was uh for Jungle it was huge but
it wasn't a huge bridge I mean it was
just difficult to get to the way the
terrain was sure
but uh they primed them in series so all
you had to do was touch one off and when
you did everything went up sure and it
was great and um
Bob told me then he said um
we've got uh
enough Americans to uh take care of
setting the charges and that kind of
stuff and it was very simple in the fact
that these cratering charges come with
legs
was that right yeah and it's a standoff
is already set so it's like taking a
suitcase out putting it on a string or
the bridge
and
it does all the work for you
he says you take pictures of everything
I said fine that's that's what I'll do I
said uh well I'm going to go down the
road here a little bit and I'm going to
you know see what I can see he said well
everybody else is going to stay up here
now he says uh security I'm not going to
send anybody with you you're on the
ground now yes getting ready to put out
your bomb creator bombs that's right
that's right I'll take a little stroll
down there I'm going to go down here you
know and see what they're doing and say
the terrain was such it's kind of like
being in the mountains of North Carolina
it was straight up on this side and it
dropped off on this side so you saw like
your home almost yeah reminiscing oh
yeah
so anyway I go down
um
go around the bend and of course I'm
ready you know in case something pops up
or whatever and
and I
appear around and I'll say what is that
you know and I'm looking and
we had a uh pink team with us that
prepped around the bridge a little bit
okay
I I'm not familiar with the term pink
team this had happened after April 17th
at least yeah well what it was it was
two cobras and a lake oh aircraft okay
yes all right and that when they would
go out
the cobras the armed gunships they
called them red teams right okay and
then the loaches which you would be the
target we just talked to Mike burn or
burn about that he was he used to fly
those and that was the white that was
the white effort on the tank when you
mix red and and white you get pink and
that's where the pink team came from
isn't that sweet
I just like I'm overwhelmed there you go
so anyway they had gone in and they had
prepped the road on the bus and I said
well nothing's gonna happen sure so and
ultimately nothing did but they did such
a good job the roadside bunkers there
were several bunkers around the bin that
you couldn't see and when I stepped
around the bend I'm going like holy moly
whatever bunkers on the road
and but one of the Rockets
literally just
serendipously
went in that friggin bunker and blew the
crap out of it
and I'm going
this is my lucky day right there because
I didn't see the bunker
until I stepped around yeah the bend and
I thought to myself this is amazing
right here I said this I've seen my
first bunker you know this is your SCA
your first NBA bunker that's right on
the Ho Chi Minh trail thank you very
much did you take a picture yes all
right very good anyway so yeah because
Bob told me that was my job if I went
back with uh unexposed film I was going
to be up shit's creek you know because
he's going to see to it but anyway but I
uh so we had um
a very good mission on that wow and took
it out and uh
quite surprisingly I think uh the little
people got on RT Michigan and RT Idaho
now they were not bunk beds or anything
like that but they got along a little
better I think well they're both just
for our listening audience is the um
Idaho was the original team and Michigan
was an early on team too that had
excellent leadership and they they saw
lots of action in the Years prior so by
this time you had two really good SOG
Recon teams
that I think were able to rise above the
ethnicity hatred that was a great
problem I think because recognized ages
of course 68 we had we had a fire fight
in fob one
you know they had a poke again and went
sideways the cambode came back hand
grenaded The Yards they had a whole
firefight right in the base
so you didn't have that you had
professionalism there at the highest
level so you go back you blow the bridge
get out no firefight no extra little
extra curricular contact it was amazing
like a snail snot twice twice yeah
Airborne that's exactly right
and then uh
uh we came back and a lot of the stuff
was scrubbed it was like well the Intel
you know is over on the bridge you know
y'all taking care of it uh something
else went down and another mission got
scrubbed because of weather or something
so there were several of us that were
going back on a c-123 back to uh Danang
out of fubai yeah okay and uh we um
um
The Uso was in town
oh and uh so we thought we would go down
and we would
look at the Uso show on the way back
from the airport to CCN just taking the
outside stuff yeah oh yeah that's what
we're going to do off to the side and of
course we had the most Motley looking
crew you've ever seen it's coming out of
the little people yes and with no names
no ranks all this wonderful stuff
oh yes
and it was great so anyway after we see
the remnants the last of the show yeah
the first calf has a presence up there
oh yeah and I'm not going to say who but
somebody in my group pretended to be a
major
and he says well come on boys let's go
shoot some pool
so we said well that's great but let's
go shoot some pool
and we go to I'm just going to call it
the calvary they were pilots yeah okay
and uh they all had their little cavalry
hats on and and they look just really
not look too clean to be mean to be to
be mean that's right and so
we go into
the Oakland or the oak Club of course
yeah yeah hell yeah they got a major
with us you know so anyway
we um
so major Castile I mean an on-name major
no no uh no it was not Bob I'm not gonna
implicate him uh he was totally innocent
on this but somebody else who let's say
had a little more finesse not more than
Bob but certainly more than me and some
others okay uh he wanted to buy a round
of drinks for his men and we were
dressed like every damn throat away you
had ever seen I mean we we even had one
guy that had a Snoopy the dog had on no
oh yeah and it was like
who in the hell are you sons of [__]
you know
and uh so he says I'm going to ask you
to leave the club
and you're not going to let us have a
drink and it's like no the uh like
Colonel says uh I'm going to ask you to
leave the club because you can't prove
to me that you are an officer and never
even if you are I'm not going to allow
this riffraff in here kind of stuff you
know of course and we're like who in the
world now I'm
you know I like I can't believe this the
wheelies are offended a little bit oh
that's right so we leave yeah we leave
and we pick out the lieutenant colonel's
Jeep indeed yes and it was a nice jeep
and we had shitty Jeeps at CCN so we
decided to borrow it to borrow it indeed
and so we borrowed it and then one of
the other guys happened to have his
k-bar on him
and we flattened all the other tires
that were pulled up in front of the oak
Club
can't chase you with flat tires we go
back
and um
we spend the night at the launch site
and the next morning early we get up and
we go to the ready ramp and we're coming
back
and uh
the major
trying to remember his name on the
locked side anyway we're getting all our
teams
or nc-130
Americans all the little people and our
prize Jeep indeed is also loaded and
strapped down
and I step out along with the major and
I said major maybe you ought to see this
right here
what are you talking about pulley I said
well it looks like Smokey and the Bandit
coming here you know
you know a whole line of M151 Jeeps with
little blue lights going like that and
he says
well I be damned
he says get on the plane get on the
plane and get that ramp up and get to
get the ramp up so he asked load Master
he says
uh what's going on that leadmaster says
well we've been told to stand down not
to take off he says I am the launch site
Commander he said get this 130 off the
ground now
and so sure enough that little black
bird it makes a turn it gets on the
thing and off it goes and you can look
out the back and here they come it's
like I said it looks like smoking the
Bandit coming across there and we we got
there and of course it's amazing what a
little paint will do for you so I did
black paint in particular that's right
indeed that's right so anyway
uh I think that's my favorite mission
right there so that's classic classic
stuff there is a picture in uh
one of uh Jason's books
that uh shows the Jeep in question
indeed yeah so hopefully that'll be in
Jason's next book that'll be out next
year perhaps it will be focusing on RT
Idaho oh is that right yes sir I didn't
realize he was gonna he's working on it
working hard is that right okay but we
want to so you get back you bring a new
Jeep to the compound we get a good Jeep
finally and then
um what's next for RT Idaho and you
um
Bob was looking at well like I said we
ran a couple of small I mean I I would
it wasn't you're going into where we've
lost you know six Recon teams that kind
of stuff Bob was looking at
um
riding Covey sure and he he did it out
of Thailand for a while which I hated to
see him go but that's what you need
that's weight of rotation went after
you're on a team for a while that's why
you want the experienced voice in the
sky riding Covey yeah that's right and
he had his time on the team so um so who
becomes the 1-0 Frank
uh
uh Ken bowray
indeed yes Lieutenant Lieutenant first
lieutenant thank you first lieutenant
first the one in the only becomes the
new one zero that's right indeed
up pretty quick I assume
oh he did great yeah he did great he uh
I um
um was his one one and we still had the
Recon team and I tell you
um we uh went to monkey mountain a
couple times because if we had enough
time
the range had been closed at that time
because CCN yes they closed the range
they closed everything because they had
detected some mines that had been put
they felt like some of the uh Bad Dudes
from down around on the Marine side
the opposite side of marble mountain
right where they had and they had Viet
Cong Cyprus and that's what came out for
the attack in 68 so they came in to
start doing that putting mines in the
sand yes they also put them in a
compound we actually had one guy that uh
lost his toes what a M14 toe popper oh
that's the reason we had concrete walks
in the compound so you were supposed to
stay on the walks but you know there's
always somebody that wants to take a
shortcut always yeah and so they had
detect I don't know why we didn't call
in an engineer company or something
right and and clear the range but
anyway yeah it was just so you went to
monkey mountain we would go to monkey
mountain sometimes and do what we wanted
to do sure and it was a lot of training
back then and uh Ken came on board uh
Bob left and I was back in flux again
so um one one oh I well I mean yeah but
you know as far because they wouldn't
let us
actively run missions like we were doing
and don't forget this particular this
one this time change this is this is
close to uh 72. mm-hmm right well late
71 right because you can no longer wear
braids you get the black hats and they
change the designation that's right
after uh we went on bright light to be
honest with you oh no kidding black
baseball hats yep yeah part of the
Vietnamization process turning things
over to new attire yes new attire oh
yep that was early on to be I mean uh
sure kind of but um
Ken stepped up and he went to 1-0 school
down a long time and he did a great job
I mean and see what was going on in the
compound then too because Idaho was a
Vietnamese team it's like they are going
to be the uh this point of the spear for
success for the Vietnamization process
Bingo and so they were not turning any
of the Yards loose to do anything it was
all if you've got a Vietnamese team
you're going to train them up you're
going to well we were fortunate where we
had vets just about yeah how long
they've been out
omissions and uh what I was doing a lot
of was choosing lz's form they would
draw a mission I'd find out what it was
and then you fly VR visual
reconnaissance
wow
do you get much gunfire anti-aircraft
fire flying your VR back then you know
it was strange uh in the fact that when
you would go and
um even
uh our first missions when we would go
um before the Vietnamization program
started
um they would show you the map you know
they were talking about six by six right
in the room you know when you would be
on the ground you'd have a small section
of your map that you would be referring
sure
and uh
when you'd go in and get your target
briefing
they would never do the overlay to show
the 37s
and that kind of stuff for 57 and the
12.7s yeah you know and it was like well
yeah you're sitting too bad with a
little flying Napa to Earth here and
we'll be well look at what what altitude
you think you're gonna be flying I don't
know you can probably fly here Napa or
500 feet
or if that's
for going in and vrs whatever we got to
get we're going to get in quick we're
going to get out you know they'll be
sitting back watching
whatever they want to watch or write in
a letter and we'll be coming up the
valley and they won't even know that
we're where we're going until we're past
them I said well hello Pete now what you
got to realize that you you're flying at
500 feet
in a valley and the mountains on each
side are at 5 000 feet now what do you
think they're going to do
you know it's not like when they fly
past you or you fly down the valley they
gonna be going like that you know yeah
and and so anyway it'll be like target
practice that's right pretty much it was
it was a real strange time but um
we think we did the very best we could
do getting those guys on ground Quang
told me a couple times he said Chung SI
you pick out good linen zones really he
said yes that's a major compliment from
him oh I I was my feet didn't touch you
never told me that days yeah well he was
too busy really fighting the war with
you that's why so but no he he was uh
you know Colin was sophisticated beyond
what you would recognize you didn't have
the misfortune to play Vietnamese poker
with it no I didn't I couldn't grass I
couldn't grasp but the three tears right
of the cards you had to hold and Quang
he had a very happy time oh I did my
money well well good for him
oh my God but um
kind of making it uh to wrap it up yes
sir
the Vietnamization program was in full
swing
um so you get the 72
and you're still on the left right after
yes and then once uh
it actually comes to a point where okay
we're going to do this we're committed
to it now
uh then
um that woman the uh JD was gone right
sure and a Tom Jones I don't know if you
ever knew Tom Jones He took over as uh
first sergeant rickon Sergeant okay sure
and uh he assigned me to RT Louisiana
and that's how well back to your
original team that's right I was like a
rabbit I got up ran from the dogs as
hard as I could and then came right back
the important question for me at least
on the RT Idaho side you go to Louisiana
and that was when Ken went to Sidewinder
and then because doti Kwang was so good
he became the 0-1 and the team leader
and they ran missions last night they
did which was one of the first all
Undead teams out of CCM
amazing accomplishment and I think they
related to the little people yeah uh it
was
um
it's like you said it was nothing more
than a Real Testament of what they could
do yeah and could do all along sure
honestly and uh we're live today thanks
to those little people being good on the
ground that's right absolutely and the
fact that uh they were
it's amazing how your senses become so
acute
when you're in the jungle for a while
and I mean uh I would
like a week before we would get on the
ground I would eat these nasty
nasty
the people or
Oriental rations
yes exactly right which is there an
indigenous rations oh yeah and the the
I mean there was squid in every meal I
think there was and it was you know and
of course they loved them they did you
know uh and uh the projects would buy
that stuff by the train load San
Francisco that's right so yes indeed if
you know if you put enough of that uh
Tabasco sauce scenario you kind of
forget about milk flavor they were well
kindly
and somehow it's so hot I mean you you
lose your taste for about three days
before you did it stuff will come back
so anyway but uh but on a very serious
track was there so are you did you get
the February or March because you're you
came in the country around April so your
one-year tour is still running was there
any in reports uh I mean Intel reports
about The pending Easter offensive Lamb
song wasn't that Lamb song no last song
was the year previous or was it they had
the Easter offensive that they did in
April of 72. and there was another
secret mission that came out that Jim
Butler was involved in away from CCN at
the time he came back from DC that's
another story but was there anything in
Camp through your routine day-to-day
operations were there rumors or concerns
or attempts to get more Intel about what
was going on yeah uh there was a
Bob Sinton his Hooch was facing
uh what the mess hall was okay sure you
look straight across pretty much the
first row of Recon cup that's right yeah
that's right and um
everything was changing you almost had
to get a read a feel for what was going
on every day
and when Bob left uh
Pappy that was our
fun affectionate name for Tom Jones took
JD's Place indeed yes
um he commandeered that Hooch and made
it this was going to be our day room you
come in here for your daily briefing
okay and it was changing every day with
Tom he'd say you're going to be doing
this today
you train because the mission is coming
down and we don't know exactly what it's
going to be we're a team still doing
going into isolation then before a
mission no good everything was turning
so quick yeah it was crazy I only went
to isolation one time the whole time I
was in CCN was this an insult to the
teams I know yeah
and somebody mentioned to me I don't
know if it's true you perhaps you have
good intelligence that uh the isolation
area was bugged
it wouldn't surprise me not in the least
but I don't know yeah but we usually had
the the this we the one zeros and the
one one would get the briefings at the
talk Center and we come back talk to
little people but
no it was yeah that the last year
not pretty
it will it wouldn't because
um
nobody knew from day to day
what today's mission is going to be
uh and literally and I'm sure and a lot
of the guys
um they were
um
D Rose Knightdale there they were
getting out and it's like and no
replacement troops then not like you
coming in in 71.
and uh it was like
well you know what I just don't want be
I don't want to be the last team or the
last Kia
I just don't want to do it I think I
will get
something else done
and you're becoming a short timer too
yeah because nobody knew it yeah you
know but we were
uh several guys got circumcised so they
wouldn't have to go to the field
well I'm giving y'all this dirt but it's
the tree
so but they uh uh it was it was they
went in for brain surgery yeah exactly
and I'm going
did
oh yeah man don't don't make me laugh I
can't hardly walk you know or something
or or the cow would bring them a beer
yeah you know
and then me I said you deserve you can
get everything you get you know wow but
anyway
um no I think the last
um
um so you're on Louisiana in your last
mission then yes but see
Louisiana the little people were Brew
and they were from
my lock right
and uh
Tom uh he told all of us he said oh
everybody that's got indige
we're going to have to turn them loose
we're going to get have to get rid of
them we've been got direct orders we've
got to do that no kidding yeah and so
the order was just to leave him out of
the camper could you fly me back to her
we were taking them back to their
Villages wow but he said but we've got
one last mission that Saigon wants us
all to run he said with the new
offensive that's supposed to be coming
up
we are going we've been asked to put six
Recon teams in the field at one time so
and we're going to spread it out you're
going to be like online
whoa and you're going from point A to
point B which is kind of what we did
most of the time anyway but 16's on the
ground 16 once with no additional air
support oh
you know you're gonna insert
and that's the kind of stuff you're
going to do so do you remember the
target area itself where would you be
ask y'all I can't tell you except they
were they were uh massing
in the ashong right supposedly
and um it said we want to get a feel for
what's coming our way or if they're
gonna come on across into i-core or if
they're going further down the trail
that's for sure anyway and he says and
as you all know some of the teams we
don't have
um
to Americans on a team
now myself and Austin Lee were the two
Americans on Louisiana at that time yeah
but we'd already been told to cut them
loose
and it was like they are going in what
you've been doing myself and Lee was we
gave each one of the little people a
Foot Locker
and you can either take clothes medicine
guns and ammo
or combination thereof whatever you want
you get one Foot Locker and you get to
fill it up really yes oh my God and so
that's what we were doing and then when
we were loading everything there would
always be
two or three more Foot Lockers that
would find a little way yeah onto the
deuce and a half we knew they were just
loaded with ammo that's right oh it was
like moving gold it was great but anyway
so we loaded them back I didn't have a
team then because all mine had been
prepped to go back up to uh my lot right
that morning
Tom said we have been asked to prep six
teams
to go into the ashaw to see what's going
on
and the team there were several teams
that still had two Americans some of
them still had their little people they
were doing it wasn't just like one huge
we're going to throw the keys on the
table and walk out you know it was it
was in phases
that's right and uh
all the Americans were in there that
morning and they said uh
we've got three teams that are complete
and then we've got three teams that we
have got to
join together augment
and uh
so the three teams
that you guys get ready
draw your stuff that you're going to
need for it this is almost going to be
like a raid because we're going to get
shot out of there everybody knows that
and uh
RT Florida
Bob Sinton has gone at this particular
point in time and as one of the historic
teams from kantum that was moved up
north to CCN well his uh one one is now
to one zero and his name is John Ilia
he was about four straight years at
in the projects He was from Texas he
loved little people
uh he he was just a special kind of
fellow sure
and uh so anyway he was the only
American left on Florida I was sitting
there I was like a used car salesman you
know I think what am I going to be doing
you know
and uh then um
Pappy asked John he says who do you want
to go with you he said well I'll take
pulley you know and I said thank you
very [__] much you know yeah I could
be in the Recon beer drinking cold beer
you know in in the bar you know so
anyway we prepped for the mission and um
we are actually because John had more
time on the ground than anybody else
Pappy told me he said you'll probably be
going in first you and polio be going in
first
and um
so we got everything ready and we went
up to the pad you know right and it was
uh
it wasn't long that afternoon anyway he
came up and uh
I looked at John and John looked at me
and he said I reckon this is it they've
come to shake our hands you know I said
I guess you're right but I said you know
I said that's all right we're going to
be all right you know
oh my God and anyway he uh
Pappy came came up and he said well he
says um
you're not going to believe this
and they've canceled all six missions
and I'm going to tell you what you
talking about some happy dude when we
told our little people and and John and
I too we were relieved I mean I got to
tell you that and but that was my uh
last mission prepping for Mission wow
sure was so then when did you when did
you go home April again one year
yeah and so what was the status that was
Idaho still in Camp and you left and
they were doing their they were doing
the victimization thing wow but now they
were going to be moved out of there
because we were going to surrender to
compound in a couple weeks after that
okay I think uh Jason actually has a
picture of
um
somebody on her truck uh that says he
was the last man out I don't know that
to be a fact well at fubai when we
closed fubai Douglas Turner the
Frenchman was the last man out of fob
one
and uh with uh St Virginia when they
came South and he was the last man there
for that one but I don't know about CCN
that's about to find that out we'll
check with Jason indeed so you so you
wrap it up you come back to the States
little r r how's your what happens to
your career there from there you come
back to good old friend in North
Carolina no uh she uh left May high and
dry uh while I was in going through you
got your course you got your dear jokes
oh yeah okay I did and uh you know that
was pretty bad but you know you survived
indeed stuff like that
um no my dad was a tobacco farmer here
in North Carolina
and when we all came back
from Vietnam
they all sent us back through Fort Lewis
right and uh I don't know who had the
idea
but it was like
we've got an instant ranger battalion
here
you know they were drawn down SF yeah uh
you had to know somebody you couldn't
even re-up and stay in Special Forces
right I mean the big army hated SF and
the reduction of force was a full ugly
swing yes it was and so we all thought
okay well what we'll do is we'll just
get out and then we'll all meet back at
Fort Bragg and we'll re-enlist get our
bonus yeah you know if you do it within
30 days it was tax-free ten thousand
dollars a lot of money back then oh
absolutely
say
but uh my dad had different plans for me
he had planted all his crops with nobody
to help put them in and he says uh
I knew you're coming home that's right
and everything's ready
I love you you put away yours your
three-pointed M16 and he gave you three
three prong pitchforks
I'm going to give you a tractor instead
yeah so I said oh crap man here I am all
my plans have been dashed on the Rocks
you know I said it screwed me up bad but
anyway that's what happened to me but
you know what I I used to tell my wife
um
sadly um for me
met a girl I went to high school with
again after I got home
and we got married and we were married
for 45 years and then I lost her last
Christmas oh sorry oh and that's part of
life in a coveted of all things God for
her no and yeah and so I used to tell
hers and everything that was military I
was all about it still am and she would
say
you know you learn these things if
you're going to be together 45 years
yeah you know that kind of thing and
it's like well honey don't you kind of
wish you'd stayed in I said well honey
I'd have never met you if uh
I said I'd have never met you
oh I'm telling you brother I'm going to
tell you but she was a good girl yeah
she was good girl you had a sweet 45
years ago yep yeah oh God bless so that
was my life and I was uh went to uh work
for a uh a retired Colonel and and he
and I worked with him for uh you're in
sales and that's right I was insane you
could sell you could sell sand to an
Arab oh don't you know I could without
oil
that's right so but when I came back in
72 you see that was a depression going
on absolutely
and I went to oil lines hit me in lines
of people buying gas and everything
that's right it was it was uh somebody
that didn't have a good job it was kind
of uh it was kind of difficult you know
absolutely but uh
country pulled out of it you know pulled
out of our stall and we did other things
and I was able to find a good employer
and he allowed me to work for him for 35
years so that that employment end of
what year
uh 15. okay so since 15 then you're
helping your sweetheart she was having
her issues yeah she had arthritis and
and you know underlying problems with uh
lungs that kind of stuff right well here
we are we're near the end here Frank
it's a it's just a great story I don't
want to quit but don't worry go on back
and I figured lies will you take lies
were you
I'll use name I'll use anybody's name
who do you want me to compromise
well you're not president of Biden I I
don't know please don't do that to me
but I will tell you one thing please do
that's why this is an antidote to what's
been going on
um
I was fortunate to see some kind of
stuff that I'll remember forever and a
day and to participate in some stuff
well I was just going to say
I never ever ever considered myself
a hero
but I can tell you one thing I served
with some Heroes amen I'm with you Bob
Castile
uh Castillo is one and I tell you
somebody that has done probably as much
for the special ops Community as anybody
else Ken bowray absolutely he started as
a first lieutenant with uh Idaho was the
1-0 stayed in the service of our country
for over 40 years retired as a two-star
that's right someday I'm already in the
process of trying to work his schedule
so we can have him on sarcast someday to
be honest with him to his story because
it's just fascinating
headquarter career absolutely I can tell
you one thing that we did now I have
this involved requisitioning Jeeps
because I heard you know Nick
brockhausen tells a story about a GP
requisition in the morning he came out
and who was cleaning it and washing it
up
lieutenant bullray according to Nick
brockhausen oh [__]
anyways I'll tell you something else uh
but he wouldn't have known he was just
doing his duty to try to help clean it
but never mind but yeah no well we'll
have a have a have discussion over the
bar about that but seriously we're
wrapping up here and the last thought
sir
um
yes I'll tell you one thing uh you know
when you go from Team to team they have
several people killed or whatever A lot
of times you would have to redesign the
patch
that the team patch would be because of
luck bad bad luck
exactly right
we would always have from the beginning
and perhaps they did with you too we
never had team patches that happened
after I left we're just starting to do a
couple of the more creative teams right
um because Lynn block was on our team
had we thought about it and I know Lynn
would have designed it but we were kind
of busy running missions but they did it
and Idaho had a team patch that came out
Bobby told me about I forget who was the
originator I don't know who did the body
with the Griffin yes on it but um uh I
did one for Louisiana and I just did a
patch a shoulder patch it wasn't for a
team one team kind of adopted mine but
what uh uh was I was known for my Rubble
my Battle Flag the rebel flag stars and
the bars yeah and that little black hat
you have with it that's right that's
right uh but I uh designed one and uh
when
um
got it
uh soon uh in Taipei and it was a rebel
flag
yes sir and it's got a core 15
superimposed over the stars and bars
indeed and it's got an arc over it that
says [__] communism and I'm quite proud
of that to be honest with you
now yes that's not PC sir and I'm saying
well I'm not PC either so there you go
so you have to bleep that you know
whatever but uh
my buddy Ken went to the Citadel we were
given stuff all through 71 what they
called
leave behinds right on the lz's did
y'all ever have to do that other son
and both the mortar rounds as well as uh
yeah yeah 7.62 a lot of this was psiop
stuff it was all like letters all that
stuff too yes yeah all that kind of crap
well
one thing that they got on us about I
told Ken I said you leave what they want
us to leave and I'll leave my own
personal thing behind and he said what
are you going to do you can't do that I
said yeah I can I said no who's going to
tell me I can't do that you know so
anyway I had me uh
Confederate Battle Flag about 15 inch
yeah yeah and so we wrote his alma mater
on it the Citadel just so they'd kind of
know where it came from and then I put
but communism on it and then while
everything was we were extracting yes
I said don't forget you leave behind and
he said oh yeah yeah yeah so all we had
to do was just throw it out there
somewhere where it could be picked up
anyway I've got a picture somewhere of
me fixing
the rebel flag to
somewhere on the LZ it was a little
spindly sapling that was still there or
something I said they wouldn't even know
what this is that's the bad thing about
this I want to offend to anyone with
this because they're not going to know
what it is but anyway
so so much for psyops Bingo indeed
that's right thank you for the
opportunity to speak with you well thank
you for taking the time so at this point
um
we thank the military today the border
patrol the First Responders
the many people that are fighting to
keep our country free
and we also thank the men and women who
have served in the years past Heroes
like Frank pulley who served our country
with great Valor
we also remember and salute the men and
women who are not here today
those left behind
and with that we thank Jocko willink
productions for making this possible and
we thank the
staff of Jato for making all this
possible and
we are closing out here
God Bless America and thank you Frank
amen amen thank you